please welcome Richard Ayoade
thank you thank you for being here
tonight but those thank you for having
me find me a virus that accommodates my
greeting style yes as long as the virus
also means no eye contact our hugging
and I've been self isolating for a
wealth about 20 years now
but it it's like perhaps this is your
Norwegian side yeah okay I I don't know
but we are not great huggers in
Scandinavia right yes and you're half
Norwegian yes well my mum was a great
hugger she was very warm she wasn't a
region she was Norwegian and I know it
was as Fitzgerald said you can hold two
ideas that are opposite and float that's
a direct quote it wasn't so much issues
one person so I didn't know how
representative she was of the entire
nation but she was incredibly warm and
my feeling has always been when I go to
Norway that it feels like a very warm
country to me so what do you think is
your most Norwegian straight I mean I
love pickling things yeah brine I love
Brian kind of wind drying
potatoes I welcome to the various
Norwegian things I like a lot of space
around me I dislike queueing which is
very norwegian in norway you go to the
supermarket and they're waiting for you
just met they're just like oh great you
someone's come in yeah yeah so those
things I really like are they cute
yeah you need people to have queues
exactly
not many people there's not a lot of
people which I enjoy
I like a scarcely populated area but as
as a comedian and writer do you feel
sometimes I mean you're so praised here
in England and you know you've really
know you've not been to England but your
service is palpable but not to get to
you out surely yes I mean in in some
measure I hope so but okay here's a
quote iiiii particularly picked this
because it says the appearance of a body
in any TV show is a seal of quality yes
I said that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yes you need to some I'll give you the
best opera singer of all time don't
attribute the point exactly don't need
to back things up any more that's not
the class is about self attestation and
then withdrawal if challenged so it's
not like you feel underappreciated in
Norway
if anything I'm over appreciated but no
I mean who feels underappreciated that
would be crazy why should you be more
appreciated than you currently are well
I prefer not to answer that okay how's
your childhood
[Applause]
good Charles miss yeah what are you say
my child how is your childhood perfect
perfect perfect thank you I have nothing
to complain of I'm absolutely lighted by
my childhood I can see my parents much
no yes that's like me saying this I'm an
only child I think people just assume it
because your work I I still AM
where are you also a spike Chon I mean I
don't know and in terms of attention I'd
say in that I think only children have
almost the opposite a situation of big
families where you're trying to get
attention you're almost getting okay
enough already I've you've really been
focusing on me a great deal today so did
you like more gifts than the other kids
well how do I know I was in the bunker I
wasn't around other children so I don't
really know not really I mean my parents
weren't wealthy my mum like at Christmas
I got presents from you know made-up
people to give the illusion that more
people like rabbit there'd be a thing
saying the rabbit you know the rabbit
have no because you had a rabbit and
then had no access to purchasing power
of the travel wasn't true but just to
create the illusion that there's a a
wider family read about you that your
parents that they were there were news
junkies they loved the news they watched
a loss of news and and also TJ Hooker
and so when the news was on I would
leave and when TJ Hooker came when I
would come back in because I feel in a
way TJ Hooker is always relevant who is
a hooker what William Shatner yeah it
was his police procedural oh man well if
anything if anything can come of this
show you you should know it what
TJ TJ hookers one of the most right-wing
shows that there's ever been it's a
pleasure it's a new spring on the spot
justice and this this you watched from
yeah from the floor exactly and I'm
sensing that a lot of these answers are
not good answers these are these are
very good answers because now it makes
sense viewed any one as trivial as this
[Laughter]
I'm passionately committed to my
triviality yeah one of those let's call
it a triviality thank you is your
interest your movie interest because you
are a filmmaker and you're an author and
in your latest but you sort of combine
it by writing about the film yes and
it's a foliar didn't make I did not make
view from the top starring Gwyneth
Paltrow no you didn't watchers have you
seen this have you seen her have a
tether okay well we've got some homework
to do after the show review from the top
it's an air stewardess dramedy in which
winneth Paltrow plays a blue-collar
person from Silver Springs Nebraska who
who dreams of becoming an air stewardess
she becomes one yes you're right to weep
the question is can she combine being an
air stewardess with a romantic
relationship with Mark Ruffalo
no not for a while because of the
demands of truing up before there's not
been a book about it yet but there is
now there is now why this particular
film this film has haunted me ever since
I saw it because and now way back in
2003 or something like well like the
majority of the population I did not see
this film on release okay
this film wasn't released this one was
abandoned and I saw it in its natural
home the laptop I couldn't believe that
this film had consumed so much
electricity someone had shown up several
people had shown up committed to
learning this and they said it in a row
and they recorded the results and I felt
almost as a punishment for making the
film I would write a book about it
because I thought what would happen if
someone really took this film as
seriously as say you take Citizen Kane
if you really imagined that this film
that every decision in this film was
deliberate yeah rather than the result
of laziness and the comedy keeps coming
do you have a particular scene that you
that you find that is most important in
a film in this film yeah I think in a
work of art of this caliber every scene
is important
you did a lot of research on her her
work as an air stewardess yes for your
Palestine well one of the things that is
interesting I mean it's hard to narrow
down what's interesting about the film
is so rich but the idea that she could
become terribly wealthy just by being an
air stewardess because there is a it's
not a terribly tiered job in a way she
becomes an air stewardess very quickly
and that's it used to be a glamorous it
used to be very glamorous you used to be
able to have cocktails you'd
interestingly as well the the the the
whole idea about the stewardess was that
at the start they were nurses so that
people who were frightened of air travel
would go okay well there's medical
attention
on this plane should I be taken ill and
also and this is actually true if women
are prepared to fly how frightening can
it be that was actually the idea so
that's how it started yeah that was this
for real
this is there was a meeting about this
with one of the major airlines which
would say that this would be to entice
people to fly because they would have
this kind of glamorous time but here's
the thing why would you when you're
potentially hurtling to your death still
be trying to flirt with students how
about how you fly a lot
I have little unfashionable these days I
have flown a lot of years and years ago
I even try to get a get a pilot's
license yeah I did you fear fly no I
don't feel for you no you never had that
so goes mad wise I've said earlier um
you know you have since perspective
everybody's got to die sometime you know
that's my line on this yes
yeah you were bang on that's where it
ends
yeah it's statistics I mean it's a
hundred percent death rate for people
has the I mean the book has been out for
a while has it been a success it's
actually the most popular book of all
time and this will only add to it it's
it's you know I can't say exactly I
think some people have bought it and if
I can add one more person to the sales
after this
yes thank you hope you enjoyed the clip
for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you